foreign
[Music]
I think so welcome to Camp rotten we've
got Lakes for skinny dipping
necronomicons for Candlelight reading
and your esteemed Camp counselors a
finer breed of spurned psychos unstable
writers and sarcastic Undead you'll
never meet that's right wastoid they're
all here and More in our list of the
best 1980s horror movies after the 1970s
blew the doors open on horror for Mass
Appeal and new Hollywood directors
became well Hollywood the industry
started cranking the movies out by the
bloody bucket load during this hollow
decade of spandex and spun down ballet
slashers hit critical bloat as gafaz
mixed in with the guts horror directors
who made their name in the 70s like John
Carpenter and Toby Hooper put up Valiant
fights with the thing and Poltergeist
and when in doubt Hollywood just twirled
the Rolodex to that subtle off-white
card with Stephen King's number on it
you're gonna be all right you're gonna
be all right
for this list we've included titles with
at least 10 reviews and according to
their score an average review are ranked
by adjusted Tomato Meter all right you
sportos motorheads Geeks Zeke's Bloods
dweebies and Headbangers see who's
really bad as we count down our list of
the best 1980s horror movies
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
The Return of the Living Dead
when Foreman Frank shows new employee
Freddie a secret military experiment in
a Supply Warehouse the two klutzes
accidentally release a gas that
reanimates corpses into flesh-eating
zombies as the epidemic spreads
throughout Louisville Kentucky and the
creatures satisfy their hunger and gory
and outlandish ways Frank and Freddie
fight to survive with the help of their
boss and a mysterious mortician starring
clue Gallagher James Karen Don kalfa and
directed by Dan O'Bannon critics say a
punk take on the zombie genre The Return
of the Living Dead injects a healthy
dose of 80 silliness to the flesh
consuming
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
number nine The Dead Zone
when Johnny Smith awakens from a coma
caused by a car accident he finds that
years have passed and he now has psychic
abilities heartbroken that his
girlfriend has moved on with her life
Johnny also must contend with his
unsettling Powers which allow him to see
a person's future with a mere touch
after shaking the hand of aspiring
politician Greg Stillson Johnny sees a
danger presented by the candidates rise
and resolves to kill him starring
Christopher Walken Brooke Adams Tom
scarrett and directed by David
Cronenberg critics say The Dead Zone
combines taught direction from David
Cronenberg and a rich performance from
Christopher Walken to create one of the
strongest Stephen King adaptations
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you made this campaign the most talked
about the most exciting the most
campaign in the history of this great
state
and I've come here personally to thank
you for that
[Applause]
[Music]
number eight Little Shop of Horrors Meek
flower shop assistant Seymour Pines for
co-worker Audrey during a total eclipse
he discovers an unusual plant he names
Audrey too which feeds only on human
flesh and blood the growing plant
attracts a great deal of business for
the previously struggling store after
Seymour feeds Audrey's boyfriend Oren to
the plant after Oren's accidental death
he must come up with more bodies for the
increasingly bloodthirsty plan starring
Rick Moranis Ellen Greene Steve Martin
and directed by Frank Oz critics say
remixing Roger corman's B-movie by way
of the Off-Broadway musical Little Shop
of Horrors offers Camp horror and catchy
Tunes in equal measure plus some
inspired cameos by the likes of Steve
Martin and Bill Murray damn thorns
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number seven The Shining
Jack Torrance becomes winter caretaker
at the isolated Overlook Hotel in
Colorado hoping to cure his writer's
block he settles in along with his wife
Wendy and his son Danny who is plagued
by psychic premonitions as Jack's
writing goes nowhere and Danny's Visions
become more disturbing Jack discovers a
hotel's dark secrets and begins to
unravel into a homicidal maniac
hell-bent on terrorizing his own family
starring Jack Nicholson Shelley Duvall
Danny Lloyd and directed by Stanley
Kubrick critics say though it deviates
from Stephen King's novel Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining is a chilling
often Baroque journey into Madness
exemplified by an unforgettable turn
from Jack Nicholson
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
forever
red
Red
[Music]
Rum red rum Red Rum red red Brown
wrong
[Music]
number six Re-Animator
iCal student brings his headless
Professor back from the dead with a
special serum starring Jeffrey Combs
Bruce Abbott Barbara Crampton and
directed by Stuart Gordon critics say
perfectly mixing humor and horror the
only thing more effective than
re-animator's gory scares are its dry
deadpan jokes
[Applause]
get enough of me
the hell is it later
[Music]
all right
there we go
[Music]
come on
number five the fly
when scientists Seth brundle completes
his teleportation device he decides to
test its abilities on himself now
unbeknownst to him a housefly slips in
during the process leading to a merger
of man and insect initially brundle
appears to have undergone a successful
teleportation but the fly cells begin to
take over his body as he becomes
increasingly fly like brundle's
girlfriend is horrified I mean I would
be too as the person she once loved
deteriorates into a monster starring
Jeff Goldblum Gina Davis John Getz and
directed by David Cronenberg critics say
David Cronenberg combines his trademark
affinity for Gore and horror which
strongly develop characters making the
fly a surprisingly affecting tragedy
you're changing sets everything about
you is changing
you look bad
you smell bad
I've never been much of a bather
those weird hairs that were growing out
of your back I took them to a lab
I had them analyzed
hairs
the hairs
oh
yeah that's a strange thing to do not as
strange as the results
the guy at the lab had trouble
identifying
he finally came to the conclusion that
they were definitely not human
oh
very good not human Seth
in fact
very likely insect hairs
that's silly that's ridiculous look
now there's more look at your face
something happened when you went through
Seth you've got to get some help I think
you must be sick you're jealous
I've become free I've been released and
you can't stand it
you'll do anything to bring me down
look at me does this look sick does this
look like a sick man to you
no stop it the only sick man who can do
that come here no wheels off I don't
need you anymore
number four Evil Dead 2.
the second of three films in the Evil
Dead series is part horror part comedy
with Ash Williams once again battling
horrifying demons at a secluded Cabin in
the Woods After discovering an audio
tape left by a college professor that
contains voices reading from The Book of
the Dead Ash's girlfriend Linda becomes
possessed by evil spirits that are
awakened by the voices on the tape now
Ash soon discovers there is no escaping
the woods starring Bruce Campbell Sarah
Berry Dan Hicks and directed by Sam
Rainey critics say Evil Dead twos
increase special effects and slapstick
Gore makes it as good if not better than
the original
ah
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you're a dirty bat
[Music]
get me back
[Music]
number three A Nightmare on Elm Street
in Wes Craven's classic slasher films
several Midwestern teenagers fall prey
to Freddy Krueger a disfigured midnight
Mangler who preys on the teenagers in
their dreams which in turn kills them in
reality after investigating the
phenomenon Nancy begins to suspect that
a dark secret kept by her and her
friend's parents may be the key to
unraveling the mystery but can Nancy and
her boyfriend Glenn solve the puzzle
before it's too late starring Robert
Englund Heather langenkamp John Saxton
and directed by Wes Craven critics say
Wes Craven's intelligent premise
combined with the horrifying visual
appearance of Freddy Krueger still
causes nightmares to this day in a
Nightmare on Elm Street
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just ready
number two the Evil Dead
Ashley Ash Williams his girlfriend and
three Pals hiking to the woods to a
cabin for a fun night away there they
find an old book the Necronomicon whose
text reawakens the dead when it's read
aloud the friends inadvertently release
a flood of evil and must fight for their
lives or become one of the Evil Dead to
save his own life in this the first of
Sam raimi's Trilogy starring Bruce
Campbell Ellen sand Weiss Betsy Baker
and directed by Sam Rainey critics say
this classic low budget horror film
combines just the right amount of Gore
and black humor giving the Evil Dead an
equal amount of Thrills and laughs to
seven
what suit
um diamonds I don't know wait um Hearts
oh my God Seven of Hearts you're right
hey Ash I guess the card right
yeah truly amazing Linda I don't know I
don't know but I think it's really some
sort of extra sense or something you
know like ESP okay try this okay um
it's a seven I don't believe it
Queen of Spades
four of hearts age of Spades
two Spades jack of diamonds Jack of
Clubs
[Applause]
awakened us from our ancient Slumber
you're alive
[Music]
[Applause]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the thing
in remote Antarctica a group of American
Research scientists are Disturbed at
their base camp by a helicopter shooting
at a sled dog now when they take in the
dog it brutally attacks both human
beings and canines in the camp and they
discover that the Beast can assume the
shape of its victims a resourceful
helicopter pilot and a camp doctor lead
the camp crew in a desperate gory battle
against a vicious creature before it
picks them all off one by one starring
Kurt Russell Wilford Brimley TK Carter
and directed by John Carpenter critics
say grammar and more terrifying than the
1950s take John Carpenter's The Thing is
a tense sci-fi thriller Rife with
compelling tension and some remarkable
makeup effects
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
people
ready
YouTube
[Music]
Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice beetlejuice
after Barbara and Adam Maitland die in a
car accident they find themselves stuck
haunting their country residents unable
to leave the house when the unbearable
dietzes and teen daughter Lydia by the
Home the mate lands attempt to scare
them away without success their efforts
attract Beetlejuice a rambunctious
Spirit whose help quickly becomes
dangerous for the mate lands and
innocent Lydia starring Michael Keaton
Winona Ryder Alec Baldwin and directed
by Tim Burton critics say brilliantly
bizarre and overflowing with ideas
Beetlejuice offers some of Michael
Keaton's most deliciously manic work and
creepy funny fun for the whole family
no we just want to get some people out
of our house
in order to do that I'm really gonna
have to get to know you guys you know we
gotta get close
in with you for
ever you know what I'm saying
my wife and I would like to ask you a
couple of questions
for instance uh what are your
qualifications ah well I attended Julia
I haven't graduate the Harvard Business
School I travel quite extensively I
lived through the black plague and I had
a pretty good time during that I've seen
The Exorcist about 167 times and it
keeps getting funnier every single time
I see it not to mention the fact that
you're talking to a dead guy now what do
you think
you think I'm qualified
what I mean is can you be scary oh oh I
know you're asking me
you like it
Poltergeist
strange and creepy happenings beset and
average California family the freelings
Steve Diane teenage Dana eight-year-old
Robbie and five-year-old Carol Ann when
ghosts commune with them through the
television set initially friendly and
playful the spirits turn unexpectedly
menacing and when Carol Ann goes missing
Steve and Diane turn to a
parapsychologist and eventually an
exorcist for help starring Craig T
Nelson JoBeth Williams Beatrice straight
and directed by Toby Hooper critics say
smartly filmed tightly scripted and most
importantly consistently frightening
Poltergeist is a modern horror classic
did you do this
uh
hey guys
TV people
foreign
and finally number one aliens
after floating in space for 57 years
Lieutenant Ripley's shuttle is found by
a deep space Salvage team upon arriving
at LV 426 the Marines find only one
Survivor a nine-year-old girl named Newt
but even these battle-hardened marines
with all the latest Weaponry are no
match for the hundreds of aliens that
have invaded the colony starring
Sigourney Weaver Carrie Hen Michael bean
and directed by James Cameron critics
say while alien was a Marvel of slow
building atmospheric tension aliens
packs a much more visceral punch and
features a typically strong performance
from Sigourney Weaver
foreign
multiple signals
they're closing
go to infrared people look sharp
what's happening apone can't see
anything in here
your team out Gorman
I got signals I got readings in front
and behind where man I don't see he's
right there's nothing back here
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we will see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]